The Joe Rogan Experience they don't slap
you on your wrists like other places
no you can man you can get a life
sentence in Houston easy yeah I'm easy
do do something do something out of
pocket
like he was doing somewhere oh you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna just
carjack all right that's a that's a
capital offense you had a weapon while
you was carjacking okay capital
what they start with 35 is whatever it
is it's gonna be 35 years and up so get
get that wrapped around your mind oh
yeah oh you oh you watch them come out
the bank oh you pre-meditated Robin oh
okay sure got you on video too and you
had a weapon oh yeah another Capital
like damn like like soon
hit man you get hit with so many charges
and then they find out you got a weapon
you got a weapon Like This Is How They
Point At You yeah
on everything
because they need more
people to put in these jails but these
characters how scary is that Texas is
like this
I only had to go once
and it is nothing ever in my life that I
do to ever get back to that position
nothing nothing like our whole Court in
the street before before something like
that happens
look I'm not in favor of carjacking or
armed robbery
not in any stretch of the imagination
but until you address why this is all
happening yeah until you address why
some people have zero need to rob people
and some people that's the only way they
can get by or the way they've learned to
get by and it's been in their their
neighborhood for so they've been dealing
with gang violence and drug dealing and
Chaos all their life so I asked you this
being formally from this position
have I not seen anything else
like ever
see sometimes sometimes I can
rationalize when people say I don't know
anything else
do you have a smartphone
how did you find out about smartphones
because they didn't come to the hood and
drop a bunch of smartphones in the hood
so how did you find out about it what
you was watching what you was at
okay so you were somewhere okay cool
were they doing what you were doing what
you're doing right now at that place
like that like were they were you well
you found out about a smartphone were
they gang banging at the place or were
they shooting and robbing people and
cutting up dope like what movie haven't
you seen
that that shows you the results of this
what person
haven't you heard speak like even when I
was even when I was doing wrong I had a
sensibility of
I heard Public Enemy while I was
doing wrong
like I I heard Run DMC I heard other
things that had positive stuff while I
was still doing wrong and
I can't say it's all I know
because now
I wouldn't have never found out about a
smartphone if I was in the street
because I would be in the street
so it's not all you know but it is what
you're accustomed to if you grow up in a
terrible neighborhood I don't I don't
even think if you don't have good Role
Models if the people around you I mean
you tell me it's I'm this is what I'm
this is what I'm saying I I think that
it's a lot of parts to this that but
when
it's also like when raising kids like
like my oldest daughter I used to tell
tell her mom don't say this in front of
her because then you give her that
option as an excuse
yeah something she probably never would
have even thought of using
but when I give her the option to use it
that's the thing like
with me I'm very transparent about man I
didn't have to be in the street Southern
though my mom had a job
my desire for what I accepted outside of
what my mother was saying to me
because nobody's mother is saying to
them get out in the street and gang bang
and and create Ruckus nobody
so when does that voice become less
important to you than whatever you're
seeing in the street because nobody in
my community not one black mother I ever
even known in my life
said to their child this is the only way
for you to go and get it it's to Rob
pelletsteel kill cell dope not one
person
I've never heard that story while I was
in while I was in prison from nobody
and when people would tell me man that's
all I know how in the hell is that all
that you know
it's impossible for that to be all that
you know because you were doing
something before you were doing that
I see what you're saying I see what
you're saying you're a person that takes
extreme responsibility though you're
also a grown man and you're also a man
with a fully formed brain and your your
frontal lobe as a kid as a kid as a kid
you knew this well you were wise as a
kid I wasn't I wasn't man Joe man with
me we was out in the street doing stuff
we knew that it was wrong that's why we
was trying to hide it from our parents I
wasn't trying I wasn't trying to hide my
basketball
um championship for my mother of course
I wasn't trying to hide when I was
working and earned something from
working I wasn't trying to hide that
from her I knew exactly what I was doing
because
of the how we were going about doing it
and all of us knew that we were wrong
and the consequences what was what was
ridiculous was we thinking that it's a
oh we just go in and get a slap on the
wrist not understanding
what you got to go through to even get
that slap on the wrist
because when you once you got to get
arrested first
and when you go to when you go to the
county jail the county jail is not a
place this is full of grown men and they
don't care nothing about you being 17.
they don't care about you being 18.
kidding about you being 19 because you
didn't whatever you were doing in the
street you didn't care so why we care
about what you got going on in here and
we're going to put you in the worst
position so maybe you can say that you
don't want to be in this position maybe
it's the people who love you or come get
you out of this position
like my mother did the first time
when my mother bonded me out of the
first the first time I should have
learned then
I should learn then this lady has a job
and I'm making it harder for her I'm
putting my mother in the hole two
thousand dollars I got a twenty thousand
dollar Bond how old were you then I'm
16.
and I have no reason
because I want a goddamn
um of UNLV jacket
but you know that now but what did you
think when you were 16.
you know what when happened what
happened was how I even get in this
situation I'm in the car with some
people that's really Petty
they really Petty and I know these
people Petty because they they robbing
people and I'm not no Rob I'm a hustler
and I know better than be with somebody
that's a robber
because it's two different it's two
different categories I don't think I'm
hustling for whatever I want you're
taking something from somebody
you're a thief
and I'm in the car and he snatched this
lady person I don't say nothing I'm in
the car
based on camera in the parking lot
everybody go in the car we going there
I'm not going to snitch on you
but I didn't take no purse
and I told my mom I ain't take that lady
purse
but did you did you get some Jordans
from the credit card that somebody use
I'm with them
but I ain't take nothing from that later
I told man that's stupid
and boom now I'm on probation
then hey I'm working at the the grocery
store
and but I still got BR I still got bread
that from my hustling
so I'm trying to
I'm in a position and I'm trying to
figure out how to give my mother this
two thousand dollars back
put some dumb [__] that I didn't do man
I'm not supposed to be with nobody even
like this
and see nowadays people got this this
weird loyalty to people who they don't
even [__] know
that's the crazy you gotta you got
loyalty to somebody who you don't know
that I even got as much to lose as you
only hang I only really hang with me and
they got things to lose like me
so you make better decisions
yeah hey man I'm not hey man you you got
enough you man
what
what are you responsible for
or who are you responsible for
that means a lot to me as a character as
your person oh I'm just out for self oh
no bro
you can't I ain't gonna be you ain't got
nobody just be responsible for you just
yourself nah